[Música]
los países de américa latina y el caribe
deben fortalecer sus políticas públicas
para así enfrentar la crisis derivada
del impacto económico y social de la
guerra en ucrania esto según el más
reciente informe especial de la comisión
económica para américa latina y el
caribe donde evidencia que los países de
la región se encuentran ante una
desaceleración de la actividad económica
una muy lenta y desigual recuperación y
los mercados laborales de mayor presión
inflacionaria la conjunción de estos
factores aumentará los niveles de
pobreza e inseguridad alimentaria la
cepal también concluyó que la guerra de
ucrania ha acentuado la tendencia a una
mayor regionalización del comercio y la
producción a nivel mundial además señala
que la región no puede sustraerse a esta
tendencia mediante el cual los países
buscan una mayor autonomía estratégica
en el abastecimiento de productos y
también los insumos para el organismo
esta coyuntura presenta una nueva
oportunidad para dinamizar el proyecto
de integración regional oyendo en el
centro la generación de cadenas
productivas inter regionales que
reduzcan así la excesiva dependencia de
los proveedores fuera de nuestra región
pero pues vamos a ver si eso en la
práctica se puede lograr y se lo vamos a
preguntar a carlos a arteta economista
líder del grupo de perspectivas del
banco mundial carlos gracias por estar
con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 la situación actual en nuestra
región cuáles serían entonces los países
más afectados y si esto que plantea la
cepal se puede lograr una menos
dependencia de todos los países
internacionales que nos importan pues
estos productos que necesitamos nosotros
en nuestra región
bueno muchas gracias efectivamente es un
contexto global mucho más complicado
hace unos meses y esto es parte a que la
invasión de ross en ucrania ha generado
una mayor desaceleración en el
actividad económico mundial y un momento
fuerte
no solamente en regirá sino también de
alimentos como mencionas la guerra más
generalmente la guerra ha provocado un
aumento de precios de productos básicos
lo que está sumando a perturbaciones
encajen en sus ministros ha incrementado
la inseguridad alimentaria y así también
la pobreza ésta está cerrada de
inflación y contribuyen a condiciones
financieras más efectivas a nivel
mundial en cuanto a la región de américa
latina y el caribe la invasión rusa otra
han exacerbado la desaceleración
en la región y está comenzando a tener
efectos en realidad diversos en ciertos
países por ejemplo los ingresos de
exportación es la reacción fiscal en
algunos países exportadores de productos
básicos sobre todo de energía que se han
beneficiado alguna manera sin embargo
estos efectos económicos positivos serán
contrarrestados por el aumento de los
precios al consumidor incluyendo que
esos alimentos una función es más débil
y el aumento del interés a nivel
nacional e internacional
ahora también el carro no quiere
preguntar todo por todo este escenario
económico no que riesgos podrían traer
en la desestabilización política de
nuestros países y también la
polarización teniendo en cuenta que
vamos a tener pues elecciones en países
como colombia como brasil
es importante enfatizar que un gran
elemento nuevo en este contexto nacional
es la muy altas tasas de inflación a
nivel mundial y el nivel de en países en
desarrollo en parte por aumento de
precios a combustibles en parte
apartamento presión de alimentos y eso
evidentemente puede generar malestar
social el grande estamos en un plazo
entrando a una etapa que podría ser una
etapa de estanflación es decir de un
alto nivel de inflación y un muy bajo
nivel de crecimiento es una combinación
explosiva y una combinación peligrosa en
cuanto de flexión global en inflación en
países en desarrollo estamos llegando a
niveles no vistas en décadas y casi
todos los países que tienen metas de
inflación están sobrepasando dichas
metas lo cual es un gran problema en
política en política pública claro lo
cual es un gran problema
en pues y en temas de poder adquisitivo
de los hogares así las cosas hablando de
soluciones carlos que pueden hacer los
gobiernos política fiscal y también
antiinflacionaria
es importante enfatizar que puede ser
tentador y dar controlar precios dar
subsidios de manera discriminada sin
embargo es importante darse cuenta que
este tipo de políticas son
fundamentalmente en generar distorsiones
y estas distorsiones pueden empeorar la
situación
si los y todos los países pudieran
pusieran control de precios o subsidios
en realidad este tipo de aumento de
precios podría incluso empeorar en
nuestro plan es más adecuado dar apoyo y
enfocado en los lugares más vulnerables
para poder así aliviar el efecto de
estos aumentos en precios de
combustibles y sobre todo de alimentos
en aquellas personas y en entre grupos
que son más vulnerar la situación actual
y evitar en lo posible políticas que
puede distorsionar
el funcionario de los mercados habla a
base de dos puntos muy importantes que
quiero tratar antes de terminar nuestra
conversación y hablemos de seguridad
energética y también alimentaria cómo se
puede hacer digamos empezando por la
energía para avanzar hacia unas fuentes
de energía renovables no depender tanto
de los hidrocarburos
es un tema importante es un tema que no
solamente
tiene que ver un éxito mundo actual es
decir se observaba por la tierra en
ucrania de puesto en tapete por los
efectos de la guerra sino también por
temas de cambio climático la importancia
de generar inversión verde la
importancia de fomentar una transición a
fuente de energía con bajo nivel de
carbono y la importancia también de
de aumentar la producción sin
identificar la producción energía y en
el caso de alimentos crear mayor
resiliencia y resiliencia en los
productores y sobre todo incluyendo los
productos nacionales de alimentos y la
la cadena de suministro de alimentos